are you getting stopped at every airport
you know because people think that you
have weed on you at all times or was
there kind of like a method to traveling
at times at times yeah you know and now
it's okay but
yeah before oh yeah yeah but what i
would do
you know i'd always just carry a little
personal stuff you know a couple of
joints
uh if that but i always had it in my
guitar
case and i'd put my guitar on my back
and and
and so the the weed would be above my
head
and so when the dogs came they'd sniff
around they'd find nothing
but one day i forgot i had a pipe in my
pocket
and so i was coming into canada and
and the dog boom hit the pipe sat down
and so the narcs come over and they okay
you got any weeds and blah blah yeah oh
yeah and so i told them
so so they took the weed and they
searched my stuff
and then they left and they came back
with my passport and everything and they
said okay
you can go and i says uh
what's up he said well you're
born in canada so we can't keep you out
of canada
and you're a united states citizen so
you can't they can't keep you out of the
states either
and so i said oh you mean i can
[Laughter]
and the guy goes oh don't do that
but but but but now no now it's okay
yeah we got stopped the last time we got
stopped we
you know everything's legal and we're in
uh detroit
and it's legal medically you know and so
we're coming home
and my son was with me paris and he had
a big
knapsack and there's a big jar these are
great buds and he had it in his knapsack
and then we're going through the x-ray
of course the big jar shows up
and and the tsa guy goes uh whose bag is
this
and my son you know it's mine stand over
there
so they brought out the bag open the
thing is weed
and so my son right away he said oh
that's my dad
he's he's he's old and he's got cancer
and this
is medicine and because it's a medical
thing
yeah we we had our biggest laugh because
going in
it was his week but when he got caught
[Music]
it happens every time yeah but the cops
the cops they they came they waited for
the cop to come and the cops said that
let them go and they said what about the
weed give it to him
yeah let him go and so we told him we
were gonna
uh we had a medical card you know i
never had one but
we got one real easy and then we sent it
to the cop and that's it
but now now i have but i don't i don't i
don't
ever first of all we haven't been flying
for forever and
and i never no sense in carrying it
anywhere now because it's everywhere you
go there's weed you know there's no
problem
unless you go to the eastern hemisphere
you got a problem going through
singapore
and you know like uh india
you know like a lot of places it's tough
to get away
yeah i'll tell you a trick i'll tell you
a trick you go through those
eastern uh places where the hat
of the country that you're going to go
or leave
okay be that tourist you know the
tourists were whether you got the cowboy
hat on or the
or the vietnamese hat on i
found out accidentally because i i
collect hats you know so
i had this hat on and as soon as they
saw the hat they they point at it and
they smile
you know i'm one of those you know yeah
so you so you connect
the worst thing you can do is be that
that bored american
you know right yeah you know that shitty
american but you want to
put on the put on the guard you know
wherever you go just
whatever you know the tourist thing that
they sell
because when you when you do that you
send a message that you're one of those
goofs that buy that [ __ ] yeah
and that's what they like you should try
that in singapore steve
yeah wow well i was i was going into
japan uh this was a few years ago
and uh you know they're very strict
super strict and you don't lie to them
and so i'm coming in i got a a rap sheet
because i got busted for bongs
and so i i had to put it on there have
you ever been
arrested or busted for drugs and i put
yes
but i was with my wife who's very
gorgeous and
very well dressed and i was
wearing my rolex at the time and i was
well dressed and so they come in
so the immigration you know they lead me
in and they he
took one look at me and my wife and he
says okay
you're going you you lie you lie
he told you to lie yeah he said you lie
and then when you come back you lie
again
no drug no conviction nothing you've got
you go
that's great yeah because they they want
the tourists you know
you know they don't want those you know
the long-haired hippie
you know that's going to take money from
them
right they want tours that are going to
dump money there you know
right i think to them it's all how you
dress
perception yeah thanks so much for
watching this clip
and if you drink coffee you need a mug
shot mug
that's my first ever mug shot and this
mug is available on
amazon as well as at stevo.com so go
ahead and click the link in the
description below
this is what you're going to find and
grab yourself a mug shot
mug yeah dude
yeah dude